all right welcome to big shoulder night
here on I've been working out did I
mention mostly shoulder stuff okay
Jonathan how much of Obama's legacy will
survive Trump and the Republicans oh boy
I really think most of it will i honest
to god think mostly will obamacare
already has they couldn't repeal it well
the jury's out I mean yes it has Sophie
tried a thousand times to repeal it and
they've been they've given up they're
not gonna do it only you know a little
way into year two well I think they're
not gonna reveal the dodd-frank reforms
of Wall Street well um I think a lot of
the environmental stuff is gonna is
gonna stick because electricity you know
solar power is getting cheaper wind
power couldn't keep her all that all
those changes I think are out living
because he made better policies than
this stuff Trump is Drive replace about
I I would argue that President Obama's
legacy is also wider than policy
accomplishments I mean when you look at
the way that you know the millennial
generation my generation generation Z is
stepping up I think you can trace that
directly back to a transformative leader
who told us you know were the ones we've
been waiting for and I think ultimately
our salvation will come not from well
it'll come from his legacy which is he
made a lot of people particularly my
generation believe we could do that what
[Applause]
he's gonna transform the courts in a
very bad dangerous way and that's we're
gonna live with that for very long yeah
right I mean there's some stuff there's
something that's bad there's best parts
of this country we're never gonna get
back yeah you know okay on that note
let's move on to something for Andy
let's get Mandy could always a palate
cleanser do you feel that reality TV can
be seen as pure entertainment or does
all media share responsibility for
setting some sort of example for viewers
well uh good question I mean it is a
loaded question i I think for us Bravo
has the most educated audience on cable
outside of all the cable news channels
and I they're smart enough to know the
housewives are smart people can watch
soup they can walk they can and they can
know that you
Kanani make people feel guilty it's true
you know I read the tabloids I've done
it since the 80s when I was wearing this
Jenny right and I've had people say to
me you know celebrities we like don't do
that because you know what they take
pictures of my children and you're only
encourage them by giving them your money
right like we're hurting my children
like [ __ ] that friend you know what well
I have to be on a plane tomorrow morning
to go to a place you do Stan I'm tired
in the morning so I worked all week and
did this show I want something I can
laugh at yeah and it makes me laugh out
loud
not intentionally it just does yes and
also how I keep up with my friends
okay did you finish your answer did I
cut the table okay Maya is a critic of
the use of excessive force by law
enforcement how would you suggest we go
about changing Department protocol
legislation in fact California is
already looking at legislation it was
very much just like this well you
literally write in what what happens
right now is police departments
essentially write their own patrol
guides that tell them what fourths is
except what you know that's the rules of
the road for police officers and what
they do is they build in huge amounts of
discretion rather than setting
boundaries that actually make sense for
keeping everyone safe because the truth
is it'll also keep officers safer I've
been ringing that bell for a long time
well I just I don't know how they got it
into there
had this idea that if I feel threatened
at all I get to kill you that I don't
know how you legislate that but but that
mentality has to change why we all empty
our clip into that guy if we think he's
got him what happened to just please it
wouldn't go right they seem to forgot
about the old fries it just goes right -
is that a cellphone or a gun let's find
out after he's dead
start having to pay a price for bad
behavior that will change babe oh I see
right a price and they were starting to
make some real changes in the last
couple years of the Obama administration
New York City's made some real changes
even while we've had some really big
problems because there was an insistence
that we stop policing people for poverty
now didn't happen in Eric garner right
but if you tell if you actually say
widow and and actually District Attorney
races have mattered a lot getting
reform-minded people elected as public
prosecutors is actually that's you know
Ken Thompson in Brooklyn actually said
I'm just you can bring me people NYPD
for low-level marijuana I'm not but
we're not gonna prosecute and that's
actually what they passed away damn okay
Jason Kander as the first melenik you're
a millennial but five months I'm 36 36
is a millennial just barely five months
I'm gonna I'm a gray senior millennial
what do you want to know maybe you want
to talk to or more
[Applause]
I think he was implying that you were
hitting him I certainly was please I
resemble that remark as the first no any
I'll ever let you do a statewide office
how do you feel about the reputation of
your generation of being unengaged lazy
and self-obsessed yeah I think that the
idea that this generation wants to have
our personal identity match what we see
from our country what we see from a
company that employs us that that is
somehow entitlement I think that's not
true I think from the folks that I saw
in Afghanistan who volunteered knowing
that when they signed on the dotted line
they might end up there too the folks I
saw marching in Ferguson when I was
secretary of state of Missouri I don't
see entitlement I see patriotism well
there is a lot of that every now
basically cut my billions of people this
on the beach you know I think the
problem began when parents I don't know
what generation it was I dig it was
Millennials but as soon as kids were
able to say [ __ ] you mom that's where we
all went downhill any kid who grew up
saying [ __ ] you mom the [ __ ] you mom
generation know I know they don't
but they live in a lot of people's
houses okay Andy do you think the me to
movement has affected the gay condition
my question somebody wrote I'm not
believe me I am NOT obsessed it says
right here do you think the me to
movement has affected the gay community
in Hollywood yeah I think it's affected
everybody in Hollywood I think it's
affected a lot of people around the
country but certainly in this business
yes absolutely because of Kevin Spacey
like because we all have to watch how we
speak to each other the entertainment
industry is very salacious by the nature
of what we're doing I mean we're we're
it looks driven there's a lot of jokes
there's a lot of things that are not
considered appropriate in the workplace
I think everyone has had to look at the
way that they speak but other than Kevin
Spacey I can't think of a lot of well
I'm just saying you think they're in the
entertainment business whether you're
gay or straight
it affects right but do you think there
are some geisha mcli in the shoes about
to drop there are some people out there
that you've heard that maybe should
possibly yeah like you have done some
things and maybe yeah it's not gonna be
good for them maybe I'm just looking for
a school or a school family because I
think it's really important to note that
LGBTQ people in this country have
largely been significantly less
protected even when we have laws on the
books because there's this this
assumption and stereotyping about
somehow you couldn't be sexually
harassed right your and that is that is
a serious injustice that we have not
made some well beyond that I mean listen
they're discriminated against in houses
and in employment legally across the
country and and we have a vice president
who is incredibly anti-gay and I'm
nervous to see what and not everyone's
out of the closet right so if you're
sexually harassed and then you don't
want to come forward because you I don't
that's where the Q comes in yeah and my
cue is to say
Thank You panel and good night
[Applause]